欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
这节课我们来讲一下关于寻盘量
长期在行业均值以下
我们怎么样在一到三个月里面去突破
那么这个方法适用于你的新店上线
或者是说你的老店已经放置很久了
半死不活的店铺
那么你想要盘活店铺
你也可以用这样的方法去做就可以了
这种方法特别适用于新店上线和老店盘活
效果非常好
只要你理解到位了
然后根据这个思路去做
你才能够在更短的时间内突破你的寻盘量
但是呢很多人他不这样做
他基本都是在前期的时候普遍撒网
然后发现整个店铺不死不活的
一点增长的前景都没有
所以你想要快速突破
可以参考我下面的方法
如果你觉得有用
你就去用
如果你觉得没用
那么你就按照你自己的方法就可以了
那么我们来讲一下他的具体的思路是怎么样的
我们一定要在一个店铺里面选中一到三个品类
我知道你们的店铺里面可能有很多品类
每一个品类你都觉得很好
你都不舍得放弃
但是呢我们也知道店铺的资源是非常有限的
不可能所有的品类都能顾及到
那么时间精力都是有限的
我们只能先把某几个品类先做好
把整个店铺的流量带动起来
那么后期才通过其他的品类
去再度拉升我们店铺
整体的流量上升一个层级
这样的思路才是更好的
那么选中一到三个品类之后
我们要集中店铺的资源去积累突破
必须是单点突破
不要分散资源
比如说很多人就喜欢
直动车就一百块钱的预算
推广了好多个品类
到底哪个品类有效果
哪个品类对于他们店铺来说比较重要
或者是说他们公司主要想做哪个品类
他都不清楚
不理无头的就在那里做推广了
推广者等下老板又说
我们不做这个品类的
或者是说这个品类不是我们有优势的
来了寻盘又转化不了
你看前期是不是做了很多没用的工作
是不是付出了很多的时间精力
还有金钱的精力
最终得到的结果是零
甚至还在倒退了
所以我们前期一定要按照这些思路去做好
前期的准备
才能够更好的为我们的整个店铺
做正向的持续积累
奠定基础
那么我们第一步要怎么样做呢
第一就是选品类选款式
我们要去选择我们店铺里面
近12个月流量比较稳定的品类
因为我们刚才说的品类非常多
我们要去选流量稳定的品类
这样流量稳定
那么你的获得流量的概率就大
第二个就是关键池的总量要多
池越多那么他的流量就越大
所以你要去选池多的
第三个就是我们的款式要去选
跟行业热销款相似的
或者是同类偏好人群的款式
这样的话更有利于我们在短期内过的询盘
你的款式已经被市场验证了
其实你已经不用去测试了
你只要发上去
然后用直动车去推广
让更多的人看到你的这个热销品
那么你的悬盘量
自然而然的就会有一定的增长
第四个就是价格起定量
你们公司有优势的
而且是非常能够接受这种价格跟起定量的客户的
那么你们是不是更加有优势
第五个就是
如果是你老店想要盘活的话
那么我是建议你重新去发产品的
而不是再优化那些老产品
我建议重新发
效果会更好
你老的产品已经在店铺里面
沉淀了一定的数据
有些数据好
有些数据很差
那么你改标题是没有什么作用的
最好就是新发
至少它有流量的扶持
所以你在前期整个店铺
选品类
选款式的时候
你要按照这五个维度去选
交集越多
那么你的准确性就越高
你要选符合这些条件越多的那个评类优先开始
第二个就是我们要精细化的主标题
这个主标题的方法
我们在前面已经讲过了
你要去重点的理解标题的概念
以及标题的组合方法
要不断的去实践才能够真正的掌握
第一个就是挑选关键词
你一定要知道怎么样去挑词
挑什么样的词
什么样的词对于我们前期店铺的流量
获取更加有用
第二个就是标题按照报款的标题去组合
就是我们前面教的那些报款标题的方法
你可以按照那些方法去组合
第三个这个非常的关键
就是单一品类你一次性就要做够20个链接
甚至更多50个链接
你一次性做够这些链接之后
到时候你就可以一次性把同一个品类的产品加入到新品加速计划进行推广
这样的话你才能够节省更多的时间
而且你的效果才会更好
第四个就是不要选老产品去改标题
就是刚才我们说的那个一样
直接去重新发产品效果更好
第三步就是直通车推广加信号的法定
很多人在这一步犯了一个错误就是
只推广有效果
但是店铺里面的星级没有提升
也就是零星
他没有把它突破成一星
同时呢
他有些产品效果非常好
群盘多TM多
目标国家也精准
但是短期内可能是一个月内
可能这个订单谈不下来
所以说他订单量就少
如果这个时候你你不去用一些老客户的
订单去绑定这些新的产品
那么你这些新的产品也很难起来
因为他中间有一个订单的转化率
还有巡盘的转化率
订单转化率太低的话
那么平台就认为你的价值太少
给你推荐的流量就会下降
所以一定要注意这个订单的绑定
那么具体的操作怎么做呢
第一个就是新发的产品
直接用新品加速计划去推广
比如说我们刚才这里已经发了
单一品内可能发了20-50个链接
那么你直接用新品加速计划
一次性推20-50个链接
第二个它的预算
你可以设置到100-200左右
第三个就是刚才我们讲了
其实就是说的它的产品的数量
就是50个以内
第四个就是两周内找到潜力的链接
也就是从这个新品计划里面的20-50个链接
里面找到至少10个左右的潜力链接
第五步就是综合的应用指动车
比如说你这10个链接
是不是继续在新品加速里面推广
或者是我部分的产品已经移动到泡品就推
关键值推广等等这些新的关键值的计划去辅助
再加上我们的信宝的保密
那么这样你的店铺才能够更快的把流量做起来
前期我们把一到三个品类的流量已经做起来之后
后续我们可以通过拓品类来增加整个店铺的总流量
让整个店铺上升一个层次
那么这个就是关于新店铺上线
老店铺盘活的一些具体的思路
我们就只要根据这个思路去做就可以了
那么这个选品可能只需要三天
那么精细化标题可能需要五天三到五天
那么你直动就推广的话
大概七天以内就推广
也就是你新店上线七天内就马上开始推广
你越早推广
对你来说越有利
推广的时候不一定说要那么多的预算
你至少50块钱都比没有推广的效果好
所以新店一定要捉住三个月的扶持期
老店一定要想办法去通过新发产品去盘活整个店铺
既然你们以前里面的老产品在我都很差了
那么可以直接放弃这些老产品
我重新发品重新去推广
我把它当做一个新店去做
这样的话你的老店也很快就被盘活了
但是呢很多人陷入了一个常规的陷阱
很多人喜欢在老店铺里面
不断的去挑选产品
不断的去推广
你发现就是那些老产品
无论你怎么推
无论你怎么改
它的效果都是非常差的
或者是说效果的提升都是非常慢的
那么这个对于你来说
不仅浪费了时间
还浪费了金钱
所以
从新品突破
重新选品选款
才是最佳的路径
才是最快捷的路径
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
希望这些思路和方法
能够给你一定的启发